if I may ask you for some advice for a
reason I'll explain maybe in a little
bit uh or maybe I should just explain
now which is I think
because you've talked about islamophobia
because you've been at the center of
so many catastrophic events because you
sort of jump into the fire uh to try to
help people you've been attacked a lot
just in general you've been under stress
it's just you're you're not immune to
stress so a part of me wants to ask
foreign
just how psychologically difficult it's
been and where you draw strength and
would you advise if the opportunity is
there
for a person like me for silly kid in a
suit
to go to that part of the world and take
seriously conversations I would divide
it into two categories there's leaders
and there's people
the leaders are sort of these
uh political entities that have their
interests but they also have power
and they want to hold on to power and
then people are just regular people that
have families that just want to
um have basic rights and freedoms and
continue to love their families to
pursue different uh jobs and careers and
lies that they can flourish and so on
those are very kind of different
dynamics of play and if given the
opportunity to speak to leaders for me
would you advise I do it or not and when
I say leaders I mean leaders that
would make the case
the pro Zionist case
and the anti-synus case and in both
cases I would make it a very challenging
conversations for both of them unlike
today our conversation today you're an
inspiring incredible person I'm a huge
fan of yours you've spread so much love
to the Muslim Community here to the
Jewish Community just everybody loves
you but not everybody
yes that's true not everybody
that's true but everybody a lot of
people love you yes uh but this was kind
of an inspiring and a positive
conversation it wasn't very challenging
although we did tough touch challenging
topics and he did exceptionally well
there but I would do very challenging
conversation with those leaders in that
part of the world is that a bad idea
all right well let me tell you from now
uh first and foremost the first part
because I don't want to lose the first
part of your your conversation is it
psychologically stressful very very
um
but when you're
when you're a person of faith and you
believe that
good work will always be rewarded
and that doing the right thing will
always be rewarded eventually
you're able to weather that storm
um
quite a bit
so your wife told you
um
right that's the second thing I was
going to mention is honestly supportive
a supportive family you know my dad's 80
man and he's been through a lot he was
born in 1943 before his five years
before Israel was even created he was
born in Palestine
he suffered displacement he has been
around the world and somehow built
himself up to be a distinguished
professor of chemistry an author an
inventor
um you know grew up uh taking on some of
the most difficult challenges and was
just always a man of principle I always
admired my dad being a man of principle
and like he just tells me man stay the
course stay the course Don't Be Afraid
don't back down
I have a supportive family I have a
supportive wife I've got supportive kids
so I have amazing people around me that
keep me grounded for sure and ultimately
obviously faith
and also I'll say this slander doesn't
stand what do you mean by that when
people slander you and it kind of comes
with the territory of a public figure
um it's not going to stand throughout
time because eventually any sincere
person will find the truth
and the only people that will
regurgitate that will continue to do so
so when I get portrayed as
an anti-semite
um
because of my strong takes on Israel and
challenging Israel and then I and I will
continue to do so
it takes just people in Dallas like we
know him what are you talking about you
know so slander doesn't stand at least
with the people that are important to
you it might reside on the internet it
might have great rankings and social
media Bots that give attraction but also
psychologically difficult to use that
yes it is difficult it's very difficult
and it's hurtful especially when it
comes from quarters that you would hope
that it doesn't come from
but you know you take a step back you
re-evaluate you lean into your faith and
you lean on the people that are closest
to you and then you keep going you learn
the lessons uh could I be doing
something better could I be doing
something different could I be saying
something better could I be saying
something different are the noble causes
that I want to achieve am I am I doing
Justice by those causes uh how do I grow
out of this right you become wiser
through these things as well
second part of your question though
about what you should do if you're going
to talk to people talk to people
from a place of inquiry I would say talk
to people more so than leaders and
especially some of those who have been
erased from the com from the media
commentary Benjamin Netanyahu gets a lot
of air time
uh you know here in the United States
um he's uh
well-spoken you know he speaks perfect
English he's an American as well
um I would challenge him you know on on
some of the things that he has said and
done uh he has an ongoing corruption
case I I think that I think he's a
fascist I think that he's a a person who
has done much evil I think that he has a
lot of blood on his hands and I think
that one day he will be prosecuted for
that
uh but I'd say talk to people on the
ground
and people that have been erased talk to
the families that are being displaced I
don't care about the political
leadership I'd much rather you talk to
the people on the ground in East
Jerusalem that have been displaced
um the families talk to Palestinian
Christians talk to the sister of Sharina
bakla Lina Lina abacla who has been who
was extremely disappointed and let down
when Joe Biden went to the region and
did not take her calls did not meet her
which was an absolutely disgraceful move
he should have met with her she's the
sister of an American journalist who was
murdered in Cold Blood talked to Lena
talked to Mitri Rahat Mitri uh
interesting person for example he's a
Lutheran he's the head of the Lutheran
Church in Palestine he just comes to
Dallas sometimes and talks about the
plight of Palestinian Christians I think
if you're talking to people in
leadership you know obviously there are
some that will be able to represent
themselves in English you know Hanan
ashraawi is a very eloquent person for
example
I don't know if you're going to have any
luck getting into Gaza but I'll pray for
you if you do but obviously you know if
you want to talk to everybody you got to
talk to everybody man so well and I also
want to say this very important when you
say whitewashing because I've heard this
a lot so also the Ukraine and Russia
there's an interesting line between
whitewashing
which is something you definitely should
not do and a deep empathy
for
a large number of human beings it's a
it's a really tricky line to walk and I
also disagree with you about well I
think I don't know if it's a
disagreement but I think I disagree
about leaders I think I agree 100 that
the most important people are the people
on the ground okay but
I think those are extremely important
people to understand not just as Leaders
but as human beings too
and uh in many cases to have a
challenging conversation but from a
place of empathy from understanding a
human being so if you plan to talk to
right wing the current leadership of
Israel
my only request to you
is talk to the victims themselves not
the Palestinian Authority talk to the
victim I know you want to right so I and
I appreciate them yes talk to the
victims themselves talk to those people
that are being thrown out of their homes
and subjected to the Daily humiliation
go to a checkpoint and walk through the
checkpoint the way that a Palestinian
walks through a checkpoint and tell me
that's not apartheid walk through that
checkpoint crammed in in cages and tell
me it's not apartheid so uh I think
you're a very sincere person uh I think
you're gonna you're gonna do your best
uh I'll be praying for you some of these
such things are harder than others but
yes I feel like we're in the middle of a
negotiation and we've come to a point
where we both agree everyone deserves to
be everyone not everyone deserves to be
but I think there's Great Value and
benefit I let me say I agree with you
and and hearing people even uh tyrants
hearing them so that you can properly
deconstruct and decipher what you're
hearing but just think of the voices
that don't get hurt and a lot of times
what's been done to the Muslim world is
and what's being done right now in the
name of the Abraham Accords what's wrong
with the Palestinians
the other Arabs are making peace with
them let me tell you something those
regimes that are signing on to the
Abraham Accords the people are not happy
but they're terrified
of challenging those regimes so if you
go talk to the leaders of some of these
countries that have signed on to the
Abraham Accords
and that are you know in some Twisted
way
making this about religion and peace
you can greatly skew
the narrative
to where Palestinians are just an
inherently disagreeable people that
don't want peace they just want to live
in their homes
they just want to live as full equal
human beings they want the things that
everybody everybody wants
and they're only being further
disenfranchised in the name of peace now
because voices are being Amplified
in the name of peace that are
suffocating voices for justice